take us to a new story here about how
you can find just about anything in a
thrift store from books to clothes
one-of-a-kind furniture well a texas
woman was shocked to learn that a statue
she bought in 2018 has a 2 000 year old
story behind it omar via villafranca
decided to wrap his head around this
marble mystery
shopping at this goodwill boutique in
austin texas
is like sifting for gold it's like luck
i feel like you have to look
between the gently used dresses and the
kitchenware i am looking for whatever
catches my eye and whatever works on any
given day
there are deeply discounted
treasures to be found
i found like you know older like
lithographs and silver dishes
when antiques dealer laura young goes
thrifting she keeps her head on a swivel
i'm looking for anything first of all
that i love and anything that i think
you will love for your home laura young
was roaming around these aisles looking
for household treasures when she saw
something sitting on a lower shelf that
caught her eye you had a hunch that it
was something oh yes yes young was
mesmerized the details in the hair the
brooding look on the man's face there's
a life likeness to the face but was this
a masterwork of art or some relic of a
college toga party young had to find out
you try to pick it up it weighs a lot
definitely solid marble
the price is right 34.99
when you flip over and you see that it's
34.99
yeah no questions immediately find a guy
to pick it up
sold yes so i
paid for it as quickly as humanly
possible and had the same guy carry it
out to the car for me
and i strapped him into the front seat
of the car with a seat belt with the
bust belted into her car she went home
and started reaching out to experts she
sent pictures to academics and auction
houses trying to find out more about the
stranger now sitting in her living room
a couple of days later i hear from
sotheby's auction house
and one of their specialists had
actually identified the head as
previously being part of the
german-owned
or bavarian-owned state antiquities
collection it's like a movie or
something the back story of this head is
nuts experts say the 35 dollar roman bus
sitting in her home was a priceless
piece of stolen art the statute dates
back to the late 1st century bc to the
early 1st century a.d and was part of
the collection of king ludwig the first
of bavaria in aschaffenburg germany
this picture was used to identify the
bust and shows the museum where the
statue once stood
lindley mcalpine is a roman art and
providence specialist at the san antonio
museum of art you hear stories sometimes
of people finding an old copy of the
constitution behind another piece of art
do they ever find ancient roman busts at
a goodwill i've never heard of any
antiquities any ancient roman greek
egyptian anything like that coming from
a thrift store certainly not something
as huge and obviously old as this
but how the sculpture ended up in texas
remains a mystery
experts believe an american soldier
might have smuggled the bust back to the
states after the kings villa in germany
was bombed by allied forces during world
war ii
it couldn't be sold legitimately because
it was known to have been stolen and
there are all sorts of war
related laws like the geneva convention
okay so
war looting is a crime is a war crime
and when you find something like this
you're not going to be able to sell it
on the legitimate art market it never
occurred to me that he could have
arrived here by nefarious means that
being said this is my first you know
piece of looted art that i've purchased
young can't talk details or compensation
but she is returning the bus back to the
german government but not before the
centuries-old sculpture remains on
display at the san antonio museum of art
for a few more months i had to drive
down and see him in the museum
that's my guy
i got choked up just seeing other people
see him and read the story he was hidden
in our house for almost four years and
just seeing other people appreciate him
was amazing
beauty is in the eye of the beholder and
for young this bust was head and
shoulders the finest piece of art she's
ever returned
for cbs mornings i'm omar villafranca in
san antonio
first of all what a masterful piece of
art he looked the head looked
particularly sad it like slumped over in
the front seat of her car with the seat
belt on and the good will she knew she
had something disrespected she strapped
it in the tail on the hair is
interesting but don't we want to know
how much you can't discuss details and
compensation i know what you do you
think that means because it's so much or
because it's not a lot i think that
means because it's so much because it's
so much even though it was stolen why
would you give it back why would you
reach out to because you love art and
you want it to be back in the country
you know a lot of people think you know
this should be a country where yeah it
was stolen and you want to yeah you want
to do the right thing first of all do
you love art that much that you wouldn't
give it back to me i'm not her okay she
was on a hunt for things it's not about
me